yeah welcome to this video and I tried
something different and I just recognize
that there is something like a 45 minute
game I just pressed on this and
immediately got a game so it wasn't
really intended i want i wanted to play
15 but then I noticed this 45 button
alright so let's see what happens and I
am on 1600 year because I never played
this time control then playing am
somebody was 1640 rating from the UK
done I'll check I is playing mostly 15
minute but 45 his YouTube as I am so on
b6 yeah okay what can now stay am within
the Queen ponds openings will c4 or
let's say g3 something like that I could
play a form and I think I'll take this
chance I mean on some sort of meat on
Level II form must be the best both
getting pawns in the center enter
preparing Bishop d3 and short castle
yeah probably Bishop e7 now this esox b6
opening isn't so bad really for blankets
just a bit passive but it's not like
white can refute it easily I still
wouldn't recommend to to play this way
it said so just a bit a bit of suffering
as you don't have many active options
black can transpose with something like
g6 and towards in this hippopotamus
setup which is fairly solid 97 near this
can mean various things the zone can
long be the start of this mansion
hippopotamus with age six and G cigs and
so on I'd cut down
maybe prepare f5 or d 5 f-5 of course
looks am terribly weakening yeah well
the question is um do I want to castle
here or do I am want to relay a delay
this a bit so that on g6 I have aged
form I could castle that's not a bad
move but maybe it is more flexible to to
keep this option open so if I don't
cancel what kind of mood loose do I have
I could play Knight c3 but this some
while not being a bad move um for faiths
the possibility of playing pawn to c3
which can be a good supporting move of
the center ok I'll go Queenie to this is
this is a thing I'm also a good setup it
prepares long castling in case i want to
i want to go down it dumb Kevin you form
it prevents well it wasn't a threat yeah
but he cannot play at five now on and
mua to is a pretty pretty good square
for the Queen also there's some
sometimes this Bishop a6 idea for black
for example if he plays d 5v5 and then
if the Queen wasn't on e2 he may be can
play Bishop a six to exchange my bishop
it's a regular feature of the French
defense this is D 5v5 Bishop a six yeah
what should like do now that's some not
easy it doesn't have much space well
okay can go d5 leading to a somewhat
passive am passive version of the French
the question is now should I play just
be five certainly good move but do I
have something better he's got this this
night only seven which um really hinders
his development a bit but if I play a
five he may be can play something like
c5 night e to c 6 and 9 27 so the 97
goes to c6 and the v eight nine to d7 so
sort of tidying up his knights position
so it's a possibility to to maybe delay
if I've are don't play this at all i
could go Knight c3 yeah maybe this is an
idea if he takes on a 494 should be a
pretty good position looks like a
Rubinstein French with the weird term
piece placement public morale Knight c3
what Ford will imply maybe c5 look some
bit dangerous yeah I can play d5 and
Bishop b5 check priority okay come on
let's let's develop 93 I put it on c3
not on da d2 to keep bomb the bishop on
c1 open so the idea is to keep the
tension in the center and maybe open it
later e takes d5 even as an option and
further moves could be Bishop to f4
maybe Bishop g5 but Bishop f4 more
natural and then long castles simply am
using them the better development due to
22 better space I mean have more space
and I can easily develop my pieces black
Bishop f4 and we should be father black
cannot do the same is
a bit clobbered up here on the Kings
side yeah let's see what what happens
yeah this very long time control means
he can take his sweet time so I'm on c5
as mentioned i probably go he takes d5
and then Bishop b5 check and 95
something like this trying to use these
pins yeah this is some probably one of
the better moves so ok likely for is
very a very natural move but let's check
briefly Bishop takes in form there's
some to greet them possibility Bishop
before Bishop before 24 and the 95 yeah
this should be a should be quite ok for
like it's not great but not bad ok nerdy
forces the normal move anyway yeah this
is the mentioned Rubenstein French with
some what we had two pieces by black and
the French and you would go naija be a
2d seven at night GA to f6 so I'm this
way developing the the Kings item much
quicker here it's not easy to see how
black should develop the King side he
probably needs to go on
yeah this was also possible but I
thought that you probably won't block
your [ __ ] for the C porn and okay well
d 4 is sort of hanging I'm not sure that
you can really take it so on but what
moves do I have I mean I have I can
place you three covering this pawn the
lazy move or I could develop further
with short castle on awesome Bishop move
Bishop e3 is also possible what I'm
wondering is if I play em if I ignore i
am the thread on the d4 pawn and play
something like short castle if maybe I'm
night before it's an option form for
black I mean I don't want to give up the
light squared Bishop this is so clear
the best piece as it is often in the
king porn openings the bishop on f1 lets
the the star piece I mean not staying on
effort but going to d3 rc4 okay what I'm
getting at is out lacy 32 to cover the
pawn but also to make sure that I keep
this Bishop and don't need to move it
again and casts off in case of castling
and night before it's not necessarily
great for black but c3 is a good move
anyway supporting the center you cannot
attack it quickly now with the C porn
and he still has this development issue
what he can do is he can play night to
d5 or Knight to f5 and try to play em
yeah exactly right here and now try to
play Bishop to e7 and then short castles
so this is interesting now how how do I
proceed Yemm one feature of the position
is so that I'm obviously better
developed and I'm quicker with with
canceling the idea I'm thinking about
now is what about c4d five whenever you
see a line which which has a quick made
in it you need to check it this is one
of those lines let's say just for
argument's XC 492 before d 5 e takes d5
59 f 6 checkmate yeah quite funny mate
but of course it's far from being being
a fourth line after c49 to be 4 D 5 you
can take on d3 with check and this is
the problem night d3 check 23 and then
probably it takes d5 then there's no
checkmate and it's got 92 before coming
but see 45 is certainly am an idea that
I need to consider of course I can also
just just castle or play em a bit should
move like Bishop g5 or something it's
probably a good position anyway because
this knight on c6 is so so misplaced you
can never attack my center with c5 this
is the the main the main issue and
therefore I could just place short
castle wood with a good game but it
feels like there should be something
better really
one num wait wait wait wait I've got
down I've got an idea very often this is
the start of something stupid okay but
my dears Bishop b5 just let's just think
about this we should be five with the
idea of playing Knight to e5 if you
place a six I take on c6 with check
Bishop c6 and 95 the idea being Knight
e5 and 95 this is the point of all this
hmm interesting so this should be 5 a 6
Bishop c6 Bishop see 695 a text the
bishop anything if it retreats to be
seven normal move than I g5 just
flat-out wins I have seven nessa it sir
it's gone two nights attacking this
phone hmm ok but should be 586 takes
takes Knight e5 Bishop b5 attacking the
Queen then I've got the the c-4 fork and
there's no no big trick anyway I think
probably not so Bishop b5 if he plays
some a move like Bishop e7 than ninety
five wins instantly he could he could
play after but should be five he could
play something like hmm yeah 95 is a
threat
yeah but should be five is a very
concrete move I mean he said he's got
this a4e eight diagonal this is a
weekend because of b6 and the knight on
c6 so he cannot block this naturally
with pawn to c6 or something this should
be five in some very direct move it also
might threaten Quincy form besides 95 of
course it's also a way to increase the
pressure on the c6 pawn which can be a
can be quite handy ok so if 86 is not
playable what about a 6 Bishop takes
Bishop takes 95 97 mm yeah still 95
there's nothing you can do really if 7s
that's going to fall you can play a f6
but then I can take you six I mean this
is always always on 95 95 f 696 moon so
on this should be five does he have a
roof I don't really see a c1 a big good
one if a six is not working then it's a
problem
okay I go for this move if it has some
simple draw back then then it is very
stupid but it looks them it looks like a
very direct approach there's also the
c-4 d5 idea I'm threatening so let's say
you would play me would go Bishop to d6
just for for argument's sake Quincy for
then he can play an ID to e7 but I could
play c-45 in this case we still cannot
take on d5 and this means you would lose
that would lose a piece Bishop e7 it's
just 95 game over 86 I taken play 95
with 10.9 g5 coming hmm yeah I don't see
a move really maybe night d to e 7 back
but this is of course varium yeah very
hard to do you just played 90 to d7 to
prepare cancelling my 9700 really looks
terrible mmm well nevertheless what my
answer yeah maybe 95 with the intention
of playing something like Queen age 5 or
queen of 31 @ g 5 again 95 looks looks
very annoying already he cannot play f6
due to Queen h5 check maddie is 795 f6
Queen h5 check g6 night xf6 checkmate no
nice yeah there are some ways to lose
this really quickly now and I still
haven't I haven't seen really
satisfying move yet maybe I'm just not
not yet awake to see it but I don't see
a move to defenders by the way this is
45 minutes and 45 seconds per move so
the sum could could be a really long
game unless some the position explodes
right now or just certainly possible I
don't I don't see ya I did good defense
yet it's possible that there's some
tactical way to to justify all this
sometimes you're amazed what what's
possible something um yeah I was just
considering something with a six this
this line a six takes 95 97 95 97 95 or
maybe 25 this looks very weird aha yeah
I I was thinking that now c4 is winning
but okay no don't don't rush him and I
can also first take on d6 let's consider
if this is maybe the the more precise
move
in fact I just I just recognized that c4
he can he can go to one he can go back
to 137 see 492 is seven and then d5
isn't really oh no no no I can play the
five re-establish should be four check
haha ki five it takes d5 see takes d5
you should be for check in the sons this
is silly alright so let's consider now a
night XD 69 txt 6c takes see takes is
just see 45 here ok and the Queen d6c
for 9 to e seven and then d5 you can
really take em unbelievable
ok so maybe c4 c4 night up see 497 c5
just see 5 of course and I'm trapping
this Bishop not d 5c five AR ok so on if
c4 id place the bishop the check I took
before I just move the King gap now HD
de7 to block the e-file I've got a three
and a trap the bishop again yeah ok and
this is this make sense ok so there's c4
after all if he goes let's say see form
Knight to f4 I would I could take and
then play d5 p.m. be okay come on c4 c4
is the right move
so I've got this g5 idea and I've got
the idea to place c5 trapping the bishop
so Knight d2 e 7 their c5 and night f4 I
could I could take and take and then I
can play right yeah after this I just
sidestep with the King and what now if
he goes night to to f6 I have this d5
move and when a piece due to this deadly
pin on night e 7 I was intending to play
a 3 just attacking the bishop and it
doesn't have any square Bishop d6c five
wins the bishop and Bishop f5 be for us
also quite embarrassing tripping the
bishop bell on the edge of the board
the id-5 md5 eat XD 5 i've got Knight f6
double check wedding a piece I am NOT d6
also might be good and d5 night before I
can just play Queenie find win a piece
with the pin um one thing I need to be
cautious with I'm just seeing I'm just
seeing that if I play d 594 Queenie form
castles and I will take on c6 then
there's also this Queen d1 idea hmm
annoying okay with them it's really not
a big problem i can i can just dumb i
mean even this is not working but i can
I can um I can alternate them i'll
change the moose order here i can take
on f6 and then play d5 this is maybe
m-maybe easier I take f6 I let's just
think about this again Knight f6 Queen
f6d 5 to be cautious because i have four
faded canceling and something like we do
one or something coming up at some point
can be embarrassing I need to make sure
that I'm really winning a material here
and not get into any ad problems for
this Knight f6 Queen f65 yet so it's
just it just gone t5
from f6 the Queen certainly cannot come
to cap to d1 at any point after Queen f6
I just I just recognized that i also
have queenie form and maybe this is sam
is even better but okay it's just a
piece
Reggie takes f6 also just d5 collecting
this knight on c6 yeah we see this app
in idea with d5 is also I'm related to
this Queenie to move it's simply this
Queen on the same line as the king that
you file but it's it's annoying
sometimes ok and now d5 winning the
slide
yeah there's some after this there's
also not much left on the board with
them yeah with all these exchanges on c6
black has some very little chance to to
stay up some trouble yeah we came
question is if I take on c6 now with a
pawn yeah let's take with the pawn
Bishop Bishop c6 there's Queenie form
it's a possibility at least I'm not sure
that it's good yeah it's probably Queen
takes a 24 then Bishop takes b5 might be
it might be on you have a look at this
Queenie form and Bishop takes b5 Queen
takes a 8 king in seven Queen takes h8
queen d one mate next move and you
manage to spoil all this so fancy moves
like like like a queen e 4 can easily
backfire but um a move that's not so
fancy and probably strong a special at
form just to take the Queen and if it
takes on foi takes c6 and the a8 that's
no compensation if he goes 'if i've i've
got rook to d1 winning yet another
another tempo yeah this looks simple and
strong v5 rook do you want and where
does he go on Queenie six I even get NAT
D for coming self fork but attacking all
kinds of stuff
he takes d4 desk we need six every six
Bishop c6 winning yet another exchange
so if it goes down q into c 5 i'll play
a three winning the bishop yeah there's
no move really ok so I grab I grab this
primo Fisher basics right it's not
entirely necessary in 45 but let's just
take it and allow the only small issue
is i'm the king position need to get the
rooks working so i play g3 king g2 and
then put rocks on the d file blacks got
zero counter plane
yeah the 45 second increment really
changes the the speed of the game
considerably and look at this so he's
got 43 minutes left but after 18 move CM
has gotten like 12 30 minutes of of
increment time so this is quite a lot
okay yeah and put the Queen on c6 throw
that dumb that the King g2 puts me
directly in some pin but bit of an
annoyance okay kick click this Bishop
first back to back to d6 probably yeah
okay I'm walking into this pin but I
need to get the rook into play maybe
just go rook h 31 and then Kim Ji Won
back doesn't really hurt me moving the
King twice I could also play h4 h5 row
gauge for something like this but
alright this is some this is perfectly
all right
now kingi 194 and possibly a taking only
six look so quite quite annoying okay
unpin the slide yeah 94 to f5 also with
further exchanges with an extra look you
don't my to exchange a bit okay well
just 94 right there nothing nothing
special happening
yeah well where does he go are in
probably just back to d7 so when do I
have a better move than night f five
Niner five is just the keep it simple
move yeah come on let's just indeed to
keep it simple it's an extra look you
only get one point per game so now
probably just a double on the deef I'll
get on the d6 porn
yeah I admit it it's a bit pointless
relief it's an extra rook and he's got
zero play absolutely nothing not even a
vague chance to to harass my king or
drum up any kind of counter play I just
play rook ed one next and take g6
breaking through skin
yeah voila waiting on the next move we
can do a quick recap of what was
happening I think this 1970 move in
connection with d5 is slightly
questionable some bit difficult from
black to untie the pieces maybe em you
could play let something like d 6 g 6
h-6 the set people caught on the set up
ok he's played a move kingi aid and put
put some more pressure on d6 and yeah
this is this position um it's a bit
shaky in the center with the Queen on e
two opposing the king so there are those
c4 and c5 ideas and Bishop b5 is some
very concrete way to try to exploit this
if the given the game so well I'll check
this briefly with though with an engine
of black cow does have some some defense
left I didn't I really see one ok scrap
d6 and hope this attack quickly em once
now um yeah yeah I can take on e6 I can
play Queenie five but this is probably
the quickest right yeah
takes Queen e6 king of a drug da checc
rokom rook da check King to g7 root GA
checking h7 and where's the mate Queen
f7 s at least this one major maybe
there's some some quicker mate but as
mentioned that's only one point per game
Luke g8 and Queen f7 so is enough IAM ok
let's just let's just do this at now
rook a che check group takes h5 mate
check
checkmate yeah this is a record winning
441 points this is the first kind of if
you have got the first game than yours
got this critter rating jumps and I'd
like to briefly check on the Bishop b5
move if he's got some some defense
against this it looks it looks really
uncomfortable yeah the computers on plus
two already so yeah its main lioness is
winning a piece okay yeah then Bishop b5
really was strong probably the strongest
move in the position I'm glad to have
found that because you sometimes play
them kind of normal-looking moves and
have a good position but you sometimes
have those knockout moves that that
really went instantly and this is one of
those it wins really a six and that's
the liner I was almost mentioning and I
black collapses
good yeah okay this was good really but
should be five um yeah there's no way to
defend this if he goes I played it wrong
if you place this there's nitey five and
two no defense if it goes here there's
Bishop c4 and the Queen this is the
problem cannot cannot save it now it's
I'm gone he really doesn't have the
moves he played this Bishop to b6 and
then there's c4 oops I keep hitting this
this wrong but unless he forms the check
and here the computer gives 95 yeah I
briefly thought about this but um I mean
a pieces of pieces fit this is why I
just then took end and grab the the
piece of course it looks quite dangerous
IAM summer I was thinking quindi forward
I can just take c6 of course yeah this
this would have been maybe quicker but
ok it's a it's just a piece this year
takes and d5 I mean it's just completely
winning with an extra piece and the
better position yeah this was really a
long long game i hit the wrong button
year with the 45 minutes but i hope you
enjoyed this this game anyway the pretty
quick punishment off from somewhat
sluggish development in the opening yeah
thanks thanks for watching
you